darl I looked my woman in the eye
sockets I told her straight out I just
said it man I said it I said I said I
said I said B hey guys he girl how you
doing you having a good time you see the
bedroom that washing machine that
washing machine is huge you get a whole
bunch of clothes in that washing machine
hey baby I'm going to take her back up
to the kitchen and show her the
dishwasher hey Daryl yeah baby I want a
kitchen island just like the one
upstairs
you going to get it too I love you I
love you I said
B if you wanted to go to Taylor just
tell a brother you want to go to
Taylor because you're my wife and you
love the theater and uh it's your
birthday great unfortunately the um the
orchestra is already filled up but they
do have seats that are still left in the
dress Circle so if you want to U me to
get them theat tickets right now I'm
going to do it right now what's up dog
I'm about 5 minutes away yeah okay yeah
cool no they all good singers they all
good singers yeah son n man I'm about
I'm telling you man I'm about to cross
the street they got that one dude in it
that you love man he going to be in it
yeah come on man you know I'm almost
there all right right no I'm going to
pick your ass up at 6:30 then cool all
right yeah yeah yeah yeah the parking is
uh the parking is free so got that oh my
God Christian I almost totally just got
mugged right
now
good evening my fellow Americans now
before I begin I just want to say that I
know a lot of people out there seem to
think that I don't get angry that's just
not true I get angry a lot it's just the
way I express passion is different from
most so just so there's no more
confusion we've hired Luther here to be
my anger translator Luther hi first off
concerning the recent developments in
the Middle East Eastern region I just
want to reiterate our unflinching
support for all people and their right
to a democratic process hey all y'all
dictators out there keep messing around
and see what happens just see what
happens watch also to the governments of
Iran and North Korea uh we once again
urge you to discontinue your uranium
enrichment program hey mmud Kim Jong I
think I already un told both y'all 86
[__] I'm going come over there and do
it for y'all please test me and see what
happens on the domestic
front I just want to say to my critics I
hear your voices and I'm aware of your
concerns so maybe if you can chill the
hell out for like a second then maybe I
can focus on some [__] you know that
goes for everybody including members of
the tea part oh don't even get me
started on these mother right here I
want to assure you that we will be
looking for new compromises with the GOP
and the months ahead and you know these
mother going to say no before I even
suggest some now I know a lot of folks
say that I haven't done a good job at
communicating my accomplishments to the
public because y'all my don't listen uh
since being in office we've created 3
million new jobs 3 million new jobs we
ended the war in Iraq ended a war y'all
we ended a war remember remember that
these achievements should serve as a
reminder that I am on your side I am not
a Muslim and that my intentions as your
president are coming from the right
place coming from Hawaii which is where
I'm from which is in the United States
of America y'all okay this is ridiculous
I have a birth certificate I have a
birth certificate I have a hot dity d
Mama Mama birth certificate you dumbass
crackers okay Luther rope it in yeah
dial it back Luther damn in conclusion
uh last night I had a conversation with
Michelle I said [__] nope I did not say
that I did not say
that
excuse me I think we're ready to order
well um I'm sorry that's not how things
work in this establishment someone will
come to you yes we're we're sorry no no
problem what was that what well where
was black Jeff black Jeff what yeah
black Jeff I read somewhere that when
you dated by racial guy you're supposed
to get the best of both worlds so there
are white Jeff situations and there are
black Jeff situations and that was
definitely a black Jeff situ situation
oh okay hi folks I'm so sorry for the
weight can I get you bottled or tap
water for the table this evening how
about I bottle your ass and kick it down
the stairs man we've been waiting half
an hour for one of you [__] to
show up God I'm so I'm so sorry I'll get
you a bottle of our finest Premium Water
on the house that's what I said [__]
Sor what are you doing black Jeff that
was black Jeff but he was just trying to
help us oh so white white Chef
yes good evening I'm sorry to bother you
two I am the Mater D here at Shri oh yes
uh what is it well I am so sorry to
disturb you both but our establishment
has a certain dress code and madame's um
deage is inappropriate oh my God we're
we're very sorry we we didn't know there
was a dress code we'll certainly
remember for the next time but there
ain't going to be no next time for you
looking at my woman and her her Deco CH
chocal or whatever you said man a
problem here okay see it was really a
simple misunderstanding all started with
that mother right there who is
disrespecting myself and my girl but we
really love this guy and he gave us
exceptional ass service we're going to
have to ask you to leave you have to ask
me to leave oh you have to ask the black
man to leave huh actually you don't have
to ask us to leave cuz we're going to
see ourselves out and we ain't never
coming back again though we really
appreciate your help that's it oh loo
mucho watch your ass man let us
reimburse you for that breakage okay
right after I burn this whole place with
the mother ground with everybody inside
of it by which which I mean you're going
to get a very negative review on Yelp
this brown is like the most lesbo
teacher I've ever seen in my life you
know what I
mean why you reading
[__] because I like to read and this is
a really good book you're a really good
[__] [__] why you got to bother me man
because I'm not doing very well at
school I'm reading at a third grade
level I really don't want to get left
back so when I see somebody reading for
fun it makes me feel that much more
stupid and then I get
[Music]
mad um I didn't know that thanks so much
for opening up to me shut up
queer I don't understand why I mean why
you got to go
there I've been having sexual fantasies
about some of the other guys at school
give me
that I'm afraid of these feelings and
what they might mean it's like because I
hate myself so much I got to point that
hate outward towards
you you understand this on such a deep
level that I don't understand now I'm
going to punish you physically for
acknowledging my emotional problem wait
wait I was going to say if you
understand your stuff so well then maybe
you should try working on changing it of
course I want to change it but it's the
only defense mechanism I have against
deeper more terrifying problems buried
inside of
me you lucky my Dad's here
get the damn Chuck son I need to take
you home and beat on you cuz I hate
myself and you look like your mother who
left me and I'mma block out the guilt I
feel of mistreating you with the river
of
Voda I'm going to internalize that and
unknowingly transfer it onto you
[Music]
tomorrow coming
reluctantly C thanks you for
coming first start the business I'm sure
y'all all heard the Twigs got pulled out
the river this morning ain't no secret
he and carille were up in the hood
together so listen up Carell about to
say some
[Music]
words okay you know what don't none of
you look at them tears and think that sh
is funny because it takes a big man to
cry in front of his
crew go ahead
car y'all know twig was my
boy back in the
day we used to pretend the sofa cushions
was a fort MH
M and we used to pretend that the floor
was M
lava okay you know what though
ain't nothing funny about
that of course this man is crying cuz he
in Twigs with kids together okay you
mean they best friends
forever go ahead
carille we used to play
carebear twigs and I would spend the
good part of an afternoon trying to f
fig out with carebear we
[Laughter]
was oh I wish one of
y'all would just start laughing cuz
y'all know you think this is funny
Carell over here blubbering and talking
about Care Bears but you know
what but
you
throw some manly tears okay throw some
manly ass tears right there that you
looking
at go ahead
Carell I'm sorry man that was a weird
ass sneeze I just did right there godamn
it can the brother get some Claritin up
in here
go ahead
Carell wiwigs always fancied himself
sherbear always I always thought thought
of myself as more of a funshine bear
okay okay all you need to respect that
right there okay y'all need to listen to
Fun
I'm sorry man you a funshine bear man
I'm sorry that that is some
[Laughter]
[Music]
funny all right let's go sell some
crack
hey hey
[Applause]
hey look at a sunken tub you got to see
it oh I got to see this you have a good
time now have fun have
fun dude I am sorry we're late man man
it happens man she talk about how we're
supposed to be in the car at 6:45 I'm
like all right uhoh tell me my dumb ass
ain't sitting in the car waiting until
7:15 nuh okay when I track my wife down
20 minutes later she's stepping out the
damn shower talking about can I help you
see that's crazy right there Craig I
looked this woman in the eye I
said [__] you told me
6:45 you said that yeah I
said [__] I laid it out but you said
[__] though hm you said
[__] yeah you got to see the fireplace
downstairs in the living
room okay don't play games man just tell
me tell exactly it's like say what you
mean mean what you say is that so hard
it's like last week man we going out to
dinner right I'm like where do you want
to go she's like you decide uhoh I'm
like all right Outback Steakhouse she
like nah mhm I'm like straight up
Chili's she's like no no darl I named
seven more restur no Craig no I finally
said Taylor's the place I know she wants
to go in the first place she looked at
me she said if that's where you want to
go no she didn't if that's where I want
to go darl I looked my woman in the I
sockets I told her straight out I just
said it man I said it I said I said I
said I said B hey guys hey girl how you
doing you having a good time you see the
bedroom that washing machine that
washing machine is huge you get a whole
bunch of clothes in that washing
machiney baby I'm going to take her back
up to the kitchen and show her the
dishwasher hey Daryl yeah baby I want a
kitchen island just like the one
upstairs you going to get it too I love
you I love you I said
[__] if you wanted to go to tailor just
tell her brother you want to go to
Taylor you said that oh hell yeah man I
laid it out right I says I says I
says I said
[__] I'm the man of the house you you
said a [__] though H you called your
wife a
[__] oh yeah huh darl where are those
guys I on girl let me show you this
guy so she's like why don't you win a
movie we both like no she after I spent
25 minutes in the goddamn blog P Craig I
look this woman in her optic stams and I
says I
said I says
[__] you said that ain't nothing but a
thing wait but you said [__]
though yep see mhm
hey honey Craig just give me the
neighborhood tour so then she's like I
didn't know we'd be doing so much
walking nuh-uh I'm like I didn't tell
you to wear those shoes she said don't
raise your voice at me what d r I looked
this woman dead in the windows of her
soul I
said
[Music]
I
said I said
[Music]
be
but I know me